we've all seen how tough things are in
the NHS the latest statistics are also a
tough read a grim read really the Sky
News data team has been analyzing the
latest release and this shows the total
deaths for the year compared with 2020
and 2021 the warring bit right here at
the end the light blue line taking off
really the week near the end of December
and that is 14 350 people who've died in
that week ending the 23rd of December
now that's the highest number of any
week this year but it's also the highest
since February 2021 at the tail end of
the most lethal wave of the pandemic and
back then around 20 percent of all
deaths were from covid last week it was
just three percent so something is going
on here and this shows you how far we
are above the five-year average now
we're talking about excess deaths and
again look here at the end this crucial
Gap nearly two and a half thousand
excess deaths 20 higher than what you
would expect for this time of year and
one of the points the government has
been trying to make is that countries
around the world are facing similar
pressures that the UK isn't uniquely bad
is that the case well we've compared
excess deaths with other countries here
and you can see there is a similar sort
of happening in the UK in the middle of
the pack doing slightly better than
Germany not as well as the Netherlands
and France but bear in mind this doesn't
include that very latest period we were
just talking about that big jump so we
don't know if that'll be specific to
England and Wales and conditions here or
whether other countries are feeling a
similar thing now the big question is
what happens next whether that Spike
continues over the next two weeks which
we don't yet have data for given the
chaos we've seen in hospitals around the
country there may be some positive news
here we've also had the latest covert
and flu surveillance figures so this is
looking at how many people are admitted
to hospital and it looks like they may
be on the way and what you can see is
that actually flu is pretty quiet maybe
because of those covert restrictions
measures it was ramping up but we may
have passed a peak the health experts
have told us to treat that with a bit of
caution there's definitely still a lot
of flu around the positivity rates
virtually the same very very slightly
lowered it in between Christmas and New
Year than the week before Christmas and
obviously and particularly high in young
adults those are the ones who are out
and about mixing most so we will expect
to see that translate into infections
and obviously the more infections there
are the more admissions there will be
eventually
it's also worth bearing in mind that
covert and flu are not the main causes
of excess deaths so even if those covert
and flu numbers come down that might not
be reflected in the death figures
because and flu do put additional
pressure on the health service so if
there's less of them around that could
free up resources to treat other
diseases